I remember asking the OB who had
delivered my first child right I was so
amazed and I asked him like what do you
think like what do you know you do this
right you you're seeing this life
created and you know and his thought was
nothing where I just marvel you know I
mean I get to do this but I just marvel
at it and I think the more we know
about us the more we respectfully Marvel
and we should do that we should
proactively Marvel at every aspect at
every layer
that were the novelty emerges yes we'd
be a lot less likely to say hey I don't
like you because of something whatever
it is you know race religion culture
sexuality gender identity whatever it is
you know oh I want to say I want rights
that you don't have right or I want what
you have right I mean there's so much of
this and I understand it's driven by
scarcity and by human insecurity and
envy and all of these things that I
think could drive us towards destruction
but all of that recklessness comes from
not having this initial appreciation and
respect that you're referring to and
just marveling at like wow okay we're
here that's amazing let's start with
that but if we Marvel at this whole
thing
the human project The Human Condition
the all the different kinds of human
beings that are possible
what do you then make of that some
humans do evil onto the world
first of all are all human beings
capable of evil if we're in the process
now we've got a little bit of momentum
in terms of marveling yeah the layers of
the cake uh should we also Marvel at the
capacity for evil in all of us yeah is
that capacity there I believe that it is
yes so what do we understand about the
psychology of evil where does that
originate in the human mind is it there
in the neurobiology is it they're in the
environment in the upbringing can I
clarify first I think the capacity for
evil I do believe is in all of us
there's a difference between enacting
evil and and a sort of preset followed
developed plan of evil right I don't
believe that all of us are capable of
doing
what the people who perpetrate the most
evil do right but I do believe that
we're capable of of perpetrating evil
right and the the thought one thought
would be that there are drives in US I
mean there certainly seem to be drives
in US towards survival towards
gratification uh in some ways towards
pleasure and that can get very
complicated because pleasure inside can
be relief of distress so if I feel very
badly about myself and I can feel a
little better about myself by making you
feel worse about yourself right which
that plays out in a lot of human beings
is is that an indirect way of bringing
pleasure right so it gets very
complicated what's going on inside of us
and sometimes the perpetration of evil
things can be through misunderstandings
anger impulsivity I mean the things that
we can that we can have in Us and other
times there can be there can be other
things going on which are through the
lens of unhealthy human psychology so
for example the psychology of Envy which
I think drives the Lion's Share of the
orchestrated evil right there's a
difference between impulsive reflexive
evil and highly orchestrated evil which
I think is driven by
Envy